please oh I popular come okay you want
to eat it okay hey can you give it
please Oh what do I like doing this
because it's yummy I like to eat me 40
at you I love food
hi everyone my name is Nina today I'm
gonna make a guacamole a I'm gonna make
six eggs today I already put the eggs in
the in the pot to boil and guacamole
recipe you could find my previous video
now show you what about what I mix the
eggs with so guacamole egg it's
basically you mix the egg yolk with the
guacamole and then put it on the egg
I'll show you how it's done once the
eggs are boiled you want hard boil eggs
you don't want soft boil eggs I boil
with the eggs for 10 minutes the first
time I made this was when our friend
Lily was here Lydia Mike so i made this
as a snack appetizer they loved it so
after you peel the eggs you're going to
cut it in half but it's hot be careful
and then you scoop out the egg yolk and
mix with the with the guacamole use a
smaller so it's easier so scoop it out
gently because you don't want to you
don't want to break the egg white we had
this group as the helpers what we want
to do for the helpers appreciation some
people suggest a cooking class oh yeah a
cooking class ever will learn how to
cook I'm ready I'm learning right now
this is me cooking it's a private
private teacher
you have to be gentle with the eggs you
don't want to break the egg white that's
White's like women they're delicate I
broke it that's what I said they're
delicate mix while TM the egg yolk with
the guacamole you know I'm gonna add
some black ground pepper into the
guacamole I like that fresh peppers
taste so this is ready oh I just like
this evidence is Gemma folks i've been
using useful okay now you're gonna scoop
the guacamole into their the word that
your was hey see she's a germaphobe
doesn't have to be perfect it's gonna go
into your tummy anyways guacamole eggs
are done you're gonna garnish it with
either parsley or cilantro depends on
what you use the guacamole with I use
parsley because i didn't get cilantro so
when we went to whole food the other day
don't they don't have cilantro okay here
you go hey Coco moly guacamole eggs this
whatever you want to call it this is
simple and easy even Evan can make it
can you just come down what are you yes
you did Oh gross don't be a germaphobe
the spot what inspired you to wanna do
this to this the first time oh cuz it's
it's um it's interesting I like making
new food I like to I like to eat me 40
that you I love food you have to find me
different restaurants every weekend for
me to go to I like to try different food
any food it's simple and easy pretty
healthy yeah that's healthy yeah now the
cattles are good for you too I'm I'm
trying to grow avocado tree fingers
cross hope it works thank you guys for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video
and please give it a try let me know
whether you like it or not and leave in
the comment below continue to believe
I'll see you soon what you won't worried
is that what you say it's how you say it
is that how you say it what are they
leave in the comments below whether you
like it or not oh okay it's all yours
are you serious second everything yeah a
diary no this is a lot of eggs that's
five eggs I'm on a diet what about me
you're not excited really yeah I'll help
you you want more that's it I just
should have been my dinner